the add in clock reaction is a very
famous reaction and very spectacular a
colorless solution suddenly without
apparently anything happening turns very
dark blue sometimes it even looks black
boom there is
it looks like magic when my children
were younger I used to use this magic
shows that their parties pretending it
was a conjurer they would say the magic
word and bang the solution would change
color and they were really impressed
did you see lots of chemical reactions
at your children's birthday parties yes
I I used to do chemical cantering for
every party and nowadays it wouldn't
really be allowed with safety laws we
had liquid nitrogen and all sorts of
things you have to understand that this
is quite complicated but it's not
difficult there's several different
reactions going on at once and that's
why you get the effect at the heart of
the reaction the blue color is caused by
triiodide that is three iodine atoms
with the negative charge I three minus
is interacting with starch so in the
solution there's some starch and if you
have a three minus then it interacts and
even a low concentration will give you a
very intense color
in order to have a three - in your
solution you have to have both I -
iodine and iodide which is I - that is
one adding atom with an electron and
these can interact together to form a
three - so if you have a three - in the
solution you get the color now there are
different ways you can do the clock
reaction and the way that we've done it
is the so-called iodate way IO 3 minus
plus bisulfite hso 3 - they react
together so that the AIA date turns into
iodide however as soon as you have the
iodide in solution some of the AIA date
that is left reacts with the iodide to
make iodine so in the solution you have
iodine and iodide which should make the
starch go blue
but before it can go blue the bisulfite
converts it back to iodide so in the
solution in effect you have a date being
turned into iodide and you're using up
the bisulfite and this goes on with
these different reactions and then you
arrange the concentration so the
bisulfite runs out before the iodate and
as soon as it runs out the iDate
converts some the iodide to iodine you
form a 3 - and it goes blue
the beauty of this reaction is that you
can manipulate the concentrations of the
aiya date the bisulphate so that the
reaction takes place after a given time
so you can precisely say I wanted to go
after 2 seconds 10 seconds or whatever
and really professional Chemical Contras
have a whole row of beakers with
different concentrations and they flick
their fingers as they go along and that
one after another the beakers changed
color the sensitivity of this reaction
to concentration is something that you
don't normally see but we've been lucky
enough to be able to video this with a
very high-speed camera so that what
looks to the eye as a single change of
color that goes so fast you don't see it
changing one moment it's colorless the
next moment it's dark blue can be you
can watch how the color develops and the
thing that I think is really interesting
is that if you watch these colored spots
appear in different places in the
solution and gradually spread out and
merge into one it is not as if the
reaction starts in one place and then
spreads across the beaker and the reason
for this is that when we pour the
solutions together the mixing is not
perfect so you have slightly higher
concentrations in one place than you do
in another and these tiny differences in
concentration are reflected in where the
color comes first and I think the lesson
from this is that using a high-speed
camera and watching the reaction in slow
motion even somebody like me who's seen
the ideal clock reaction hundreds of
times can learn new things about it you
can see how things are occurring
in quite a different way and we are
hoping to show you all sorts of
different reactions
explosions all sorts of things in slow
motion and then I hope we're going to
learn lots of new things